[Music]
cells divide and in the process they
create duplicates of single-celled
organisms or they fill out the bodies of
multicellular life it's a process
without which life as we know it could
not exist it sustains individuals and
species alike and on journey to the
micro cosmos
we've been privy to this vital sequence
quite a lot at times the division looks
a bit like this two cells in the middle
of pulling apart from each other or
maybe they look a bit like these spiky
guys clearly ready to move on to the
next stage of their lives apart from
each other except these are not examples
of cell division what you've been
watching are not two single-celled
organisms undergoing the last steps of
what will finally separate them no this
is one cell belonging to the order of
Desmond's a type of green algae that
takes symmetry and beauty to a new and
sometimes mysterious level there are
thousands and thousands of species of
Desmond's
and the ways they exhibit their symmetry
varies accordingly
sometimes they repeat a more rounded
shape other times the microscopic mirror
creates more of a crescent or rod shape
the underlying composition however
follows a blueprint these freshwater
microbes are unicellular though some
species form long-chain colonies each
desmond cell is made of two symmetrical
halves or semi cells connected by a thin
region called the isthmus that also
holds the cell's nucleus that
isthmus of course is from geography
narrow strip of land that connects to
larger pieces of land inside this micro
Styria are as you might tell from the
green color chloroplasts but there are
only two of them each one large and knit
into the various nooks and crannies of
their respective semi cells it's
remarkable to consider just how green
one or two chloroplasts can be and just
take a look at this dead micro stereo
store contact the vivid color gone with
the rest of its life-giving processes
less elegant in theory but as with
everything they seem to do striking to
observe many Desmond's release a
gelatinous substance from their pores
this secretion forms a Musil a genus
cell layer around themselves which acts
as a boundary that might help keep the
cell protected or might function to trap
nutrients even now we're not sure we
started off today comparing Desmond's to
dividing cells and maybe even trying to
trick you into confusing the two but
Desmond's do also divide well sometimes
they actually reproduce sexually through
conjugation but in observing its asexual
reproduction and cell division we can
find an important though invisible
difference between des meds and the
otherwise similar semi cells their age
Desmond's divide at the isthmus
separating the two half-cells that then
have to grow out a new semi cell this
means that within each desmond each half
cell might be different ages you might
very well be looking at whatever the
green algae semi cell equivalent of an
adult is conjoined through the isthmus
to its younger mirror it's like having
half of your body be a child
Desmond's aren't unique in having some
kind of symmetry we see symmetry all
across nature to the extent where
asymmetry might reveal more about how an
organism works than the symmetry does
but this kind of mirrored semi cell
arrangement is particularly striking to
look at and to consider which leads
naturally to the question why we haven't
yet dug up any scientific literature
that can explain what advantage this
symmetry might provide though of course
we might also be seeking the simplicity
of easy evolutionary answers when
reality is more complex but if you do
have an answer or even just a guess let
us know because at the moment we don't
have any symmetry however is only one
part of what makes Desmond's so striking
to look at most Desmond's have these
strange crystals inside of them crystals
are tiny and their paths are impacted by
the movement of individual water
molecules that fill up the cell and
collide into those crystals creating
frantic movements that is also known as
Brownian motion as we shine polarized
light on those crystals we can see them
dancing and lighting up the green around
them as if it's a holiday season in the
micro cosmos but what are the crystals
for
they have to be for something but again
we do not know microbiologists are still
working to figure it out but whatever
specific need they are filling these
crystals may play a role in parsing
through a big chemical question how do
we clean up radioactive waste now this
might not be a question you'd expect to
be answered in the form of a lost areum
a Desmond that looks a bit like a green
banana but klosty reom collects barium
from its surroundings as the barium gets
shuffled into the cost areum's
sulfate rich vacuoles it precipitates
into crystals which you can see
compartmentalized but still moving in
the tip again these crystals are
mysterious we don't know what purpose
they serve or even if they serve a
purpose but in studying them scientists
have observed that under certain
conditions
PLoS terraeum monolith Ihram can collect
strontium from the water and within 30
to 60 minutes precipitate it in the very
same vacuoles that it uses to create its
barium crystals this talent might be a
handy one to have when say you're tasked
with selectively clearing out
radioactive strontium containing water
following a nuclear disaster however we
wanted to note that the experiments
demonstrating that Kloss terraeum can
take in strontium were not designed to
test to see how well the organism can
handle radioactivity so while it can
definitely pick up strontium it might
not be happy picking up a radioactive
strontium so the application here still
a hypothetical scientific caveats aside
it's tempting to fully indulge that
train of thought and to envision a world
where microbes save us from ourselves
after all these are organisms whose own
symmetric morphology imply order even as
they house the random
motion of mysterious jittery crystals
but whether Desmond's serve to help us
contend with future disasters or not
their striking shapes and structure
provide us with another service the
simple beauty of the micro cosmos thank
you for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us and thank you especially to
all of these people who make journey to
the micro cosmos possible by supporting
us on patreon if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes James
Weiss check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to see more
from us here at journey to the micro
cosmos there is always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]